i think the president will fade away
a lot faster than he wants to there is
no future
uh with trumpism there were plenty of
republicans that outperformed donald
trump
at the ballot box and so we should be
looking you know
forward not looking back there are less
and less people that
would consider themselves trump
republicans you know as the emotion
wears off
um so i think in six months it's not
going to be necessarily the party of
donald trump
i think adam means fewer and fewer
people it's a common mistake
well if you only watch cnn you might
think those voices are representative of
the gop
post-trump but what's the real truth
well in the latest nbc news poll
87 percent of republicans approved of
trump
virtually unchanged nbc had to admit
from right before the election
now the same number opposed impeachment
according to a new monmouth poll so it
seems that
despite what you just heard trump's
america first does have a future
one gop voters seem to like at least the
policies
here with her perspective on things
nikki haley former u.s ambassador to the
u.n
and founder of save america pac
all right ambassador haley thanks for
being here tonight
where do you see the republican party
going as the months and years
move forward and do you see yourself
having a part in it well i think the
republican party should continue to be
the party of solutions that's what we've
always been we've when it comes to
policies when it comes to anything that
brings about economic freedom and
opportunities for people
that's who we are and i think you know
it's funny for
everyone trying to determine where the
party goes we should not want to go back
to the republican party before
trump we gained a lot of people that
were
unheard unseen many of whom like i grew
up in south carolina had just been
misunderstood
we want to keep them in the party but
the reality is we lost a lot of women
and we lost a lot of college educated
we want to bring them in and we want to
expand the tent
but the way we expand the tent is by
going back to
what has always made us the stronger
party
that we believe in freedom of speech we
believe in freedom of religion we
believe
that every person has an opportunity if
they're given the tools to do it and
what you're seeing the democratic party
do now is
they've now gone to where they're the
party of censorship and they're the
party of government control
and this is going to be a real
opportunity for us to
see what we've been dealt which is a
tough hand we don't have the white house
we don't have the senate we don't have
the house
but we can't be quiet about it 2022 is
right around the corner
we have to start getting focused on how
we're going to win the house back how
we're going to win the senate back and
how we're going to pick up governor's
feet
and i think we do it i'm sorry to
interrupt but we
we did really well in the state
legislatures which is a great sign
obviously picked up a number of seats in
the house you also said that you thought
the president president trump would be
judged harshly
because of what happened at the capitol
i'm not sure most republican voters
agree with you on that would you like to
expand on why you think that
moving forward yeah january 6th was a
tough day
and and honestly the the actions the
president had
since election day were not his finest
and for me it troubles me greatly
because
i'm really proud of the successes of the
trump administration whether it was
foreign policy or domestic policy
we should embrace those those were the
right policies that's what our party
cares about that's what we were
looking to do i mean just if you look at
the foreign policy side
the strength that we were able to show
as america was something that's really
important
the actions of the president post
january 6 weren't
post-election day were not great what
happened on january 6th was not great
does he deserve to be impeached
absolutely not against impeachment
yeah you'd vote against him absolutely
and that's where you were
just kicked him out you would part ways
with
uh for instance mitt romney who will be
voting it sounds like
for impeachment for for to convict at
least it sounds that way
i don't even think there's a basis for
impeachment i mean the idea that they're
even bringing this up they didn't even
have a hearing in the house
now they're going to turn around and
bring about impeachment yet they say
they're for unity
i mean they they beat him up before he
got into office they're beating him up
after he leaves office
i mean at some point i mean give the man
a break
i mean move on if you truly are about
moving on move on the idea that they're
going to do impeachment that's not going
to bring our country together that's
only dividing our country
when will you make a decision about 2024
nobody wants to think about another
presidential election i think everybody
wants to think about
what we're going to do now if you look
at just the days since biden has started
he's trying to see how many executive
orders he can sign
but there's no strategy there's no
vision to it he's going to jump and get
into the world health organization again
but you're not going to have a security
council meeting asking
china to what they knew when they knew
how they did it he's going to jump into
the paris climate agreement
but you're not going to go and ask india
and china before you get in
to come back and make sure they slow
their emissions now and not 10 years
from now
you're letting iranian nuclear weapons
get produced
and you're going to jump back into the
iran deal without using those sanctions
as leverage
and god forbid you're going to get back
into the awful human rights council
without ever holding them accountable on
their political guys
yeah it's all about how elections have
consequences yeah
elections have consequences and he's all
about the numbers of the transactions
but what he's doing is he's showing us
to have a very weak hand
to the world and i don't know that
that's i mean
literally russia and china are very
happy right now if you end
fracking the one thing we had against
russia was they
hated that we were energy independent to
ban fracking
and not even talk to these governors
about the thousands of families that are
going to lose their
jobs that's not what you do that's not a
president that's about unifying
that's about a president that wants to
hurt the republican party and continue
to kick us we have to stand up and we
have to continue to fight
ambassador haley come back soon thank
you so much for joining us tonight great
to see you